We have seen two versions
of the Bayes rule--
one involving two discrete
random variables, and another
that involves two continuous
random variables.
But there are many situations
in real life when one has to
deal simultaneously
with discrete and
continuous random variables.
For example, you may want to
recover a discrete digital
signal that was sent to you,
but the signal has been
corrupted by continuous noise so
that your observation is a
continuous random variable.
So suppose that we have a
discrete random variable K,
and another continuous random
variable, Y. In order to get a
variant of the Bayes rule that
applies to this situation, we
will proceed as in the
more standard cases.
We will use the multiplication
rule twice to get two
alternative expressions
for the probability
of two events happening.
We will equate those
expressions, and from these,
derive a version of
the Bayes rule.
So we will look at the
probability that the discrete
random variable takes on a
certain numerical value, and,
simultaneously, the continuous
random variable takes a value
inside a certain
small interval.
So here, delta is a positive
number, which we will take to
be very small.
And in fact, we will be
interested in the limiting
case as delta goes to 0.
So now we use the multiplication
rule.
The probability of two events is
equal to the probability of
the first event times the
conditional probability of the
second event given that the
first event has occurred.
But we know that we can use the
multiplication rule in any
order, so the probability of two
events happening can also
be written as the probability
that the second event occurs
times the conditional
probability that the first
event occurs, given that the
second event has occurred.
So these two expressions
that we obtain from the
multiplication rule
have to be equal.
Let us rewrite those expressions
using PMF notation
and PDF notation.
What do we have here?
The probability that a discrete
random variable takes
on a certain value--
that's just the PMF of this
random variable evaluated at a
particular point.
And what do we have here?
The probability that the
random variable, Y, a
continuous random variable,
takes values inside an
interval is always equal to
the PDF of that random
variable times the length
of this interval.
And this is an approximate
equality.
However, because here we're
talking about the probability
of being in a small interval
conditioned on a certain
event, we should be using
a conditional PDF.
It's the conditional PDF
conditioned on the random
variable, capital K, and
conditioned on the specific
event that this discrete random
variable takes on a
certain value, little k.
Let us do a similar notation
change for the second
expression.
Here we have the probability--
the unconditional
probability--
that Y takes a value inside a
small interval, and when delta
is small, this is approximately
equal to the PDF
of the random variable Y times
the length of the interval.
And what do we have here?
The probability that a discrete
random variable takes
on a certain value, that just
corresponds to the PMF of that
the random variable.
However, we're talking about a
conditional probability given
that a random variable Y takes
a value that's approximately
equal to a certain little y.
So this is a notation that we
have not used before, but its
meaning should be unambiguous
at this point.
But just by arguing by analogy
to what we have been doing all
along, it's a PMF of a discrete
random variable.
But it is a conditional PMF.
It describes to us the
probability distribution of
the discrete random variable K
when the random variable Y,
which happens to be a continuous
one, takes on a
specific value.
So we can cancel the deltas from
both sides, and we have
that this expression is
approximately equal to that
expression, and this approximate
equality is more
and more exact as we
send delta to 0.
But delta has already
disappeared from here, so we
can set these two expressions
equal to each other.
At this point, now, we can take
this term and move it to
the other side of the equality
so it will go to the
denominator.
And we obtain this version
of the Bayes rule.
It gives us the conditional
probability of a random
variable K given that a certain
continuous random
variable Y has taken on
a specific value.
So this version is useful if
we have a continuous noisy
observation, Y, on the basis of
which we're trying to say
something, to make inferences
about the discrete random
variable K. And in order to
apply the Bayes rule, we need
to know the unconditional
distribution of the random
variable K, and we also need to
have a model of the noisy
observation--
a model of that observation
under each possible
conditional universe.
So for any possibility for the
random variable K, we need to
know the distribution of
the random variable Y.
Or, alternatively, we can take
this term and send it to the
denominator of the other side,
and we get a different version
of the Bayes rule.
This version of the Bayes rule
applies if we're trying to
make an inference about a
continuous random variable Y,
given that we know the value
of a certain related
observation, K, of a random
variable, capital K.
In both versions of the Bayes
rule, there's also a
denominator term which needs
to be evaluated.
This term gets evaluated similar
to the cases that we
have considered earlier, and
they are determined by using a
suitable version of the total
probability theorem.
This is a version of the total
probability theory that we
have already seen.
We have a conditional density of
Y under different scenarios
for the random variable capital
K, and we get the
density of Y by considering the
conditional densities and
weighing them according to the
probabilities of the different
discrete scenarios.
This version of the total
probability theorem is
something that we have not
proved so far, and we
have not seen it.
On the other hand, it's
not hard to derive.
If we fix the value of k, this
is a density, and therefore it
must integrate to 1.
So the integral of this ratio,
with respect to y, has to be
equal to 1.
Now, there's no y in the
denominator, so the integral
of the numerator divided by
the denominator has to be
equal to 1, which means that the
denominator must be equal
to the integral of the numerator
when we integrate
overall y's, and this
is just what this
expression is saying.
So what we will do next will be
to consider one example for
each one of these two cases of
the Bayes rule that we have
just derived.